[Music]
mr. Sakawa may I present miss Roxanne
cause it is a great pleasure the
pleasure's all mine
[Music]
[Music]
I'm with International Committee of the
Red Cross our demands all political
prisoners must be freed it is up to the
government if there is blood it will be
in their hands no one has to die we'll
have to some day
[Music]
he's always smooth by your work he must
love opera
for him your voice his operas I'm Sookie
peddle puzzle
let's put a border
is it true that the government is
considering shooting Assam guava vanilla
so as to pin it on the rebels
we need to free your brothers and
sisters
we will not surrender to these
government criminals
we hear her all they have the gusto la
musica
oh yeah massa
how did I do we will not last long human
so that her girl
do we care now more than four I want you
to see look at without them when they
shoot the beautiful boys perhaps they
will find her so much
I think I should say
[Music]
I want you to sing loudly enough let
these animals outside come here
it's time
[Music]
you